lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
revisar lo que creo que es la manera más
intuitiva de ordenar una lista es la
manera en que yo lo haría si tuviera que
ordenar una lista manualmente pero
quiero dejar claro también que no es la
manera más eficiente de ordenar una
lista de cualquier manera creo que es un
buen punto para iniciar en el
ordenamiento de listas y le llamaremos
ordenamiento por inserción ordenamiento
por inserción les daré una descripción
gráfica del algoritmo de ordenamiento
por inserción y sé que la palabra
algoritmo suena como algo fantástico
pero un algoritmo es solo una manera de
hacer algo el proceso para hacer algo el
método para hacer alguna cosa un
programa es una implementación
específica de un algoritmo una vez que
tengo un algoritmo general lo puedo
implementar en python ence en java en
cualquiera de esos lenguajes específicos
pero estarían implementando la misma
forma de hacer un ordenamiento y es lo
que quiero describir el algoritmo de
ordenamiento por inserción
así que empecemos con un ejemplo simple
digamos que tengo una lista una lista de
payton porque estaremos trabajando en
python para esto y esta lista es 7 3 1 2
4 6 y la manera en que hacemos
ordenamiento por inserción es
recorriendo cada elemento y comparando
con el elemento anterior y si es menor
que el elemento anterior lo ponemos
justo antes déjenme mostrarles de lo que
estoy hablando podríamos empezar con el
7 el elemento 0 de esta lista pero
cuando empiezan con el elemento 0 vemos
que no hay nada antes con que comparar
este elemento así que no tiene sentido
empezar con el elemento cero si queremos
escribir este algoritmo debemos empezar
con el primer elemento y si este es el
elemento 0 entonces empezamos con el
primer elemento que es este que está
aquí no se confundan cuando decimos
primer elemento el primero es este de
aquí este es el elemento 0 entonces
empezamos con el 3 y lo comparamos con
todos los elementos que están
antes que él y tan pronto como
encuentren un elemento que sea mayor que
el 3 insertan el 3 en esa parte de la
lista lo que hacemos entonces es decir 3
es menor que 7 o si el 13 es menor que
el 7 y lo que queremos hacer es cambiar
el 7 y ponerlo en donde está el 3 dejen
de poner este 3 aquí afuera estoy
tratando de comparar el 3 con todo lo
que está antes ok entonces decimos otra
vez 3 es menor que 7 si es menor que 7
entonces vamos a poner el 7 en el lugar
del 3 del 7 en el lugar del 3 y vamos a
poner el 3 en el lugar del 7 el 3 en el
lugar del 7 especialmente porque no hay
nada más con que comparar el 3 ya no hay
más elementos antes del elemento cero
así que ponemos en 3 justo ahí entonces
nuestra lista ahora se va a ver así 3 7
2 4 y 6 y una cosa que encontrarán
interesante hay que poner atención en
esto es que mientras construimos esta
lista el elemento 0 es definitivamente
menor que el primer elemento y todos los
elementos hasta el primer elemento
incluyendo el primer elemento están
ordenados otra vez todos los elementos
hasta el primer elemento incluyendo el
primer elemento están ordenados entonces
conforme vayamos avanzando en los
elementos de esta lista y vayamos
haciendo las comparaciones y los cambios
la lista quedará ordenada hasta el
elemento que hayamos trabajado y veremos
esto en un momento así que ya hicimos el
primer índice ahora vamos al segundo
elemento que es este 1 que tenemos aquí
tomamos este 1 y lo voy a poner de este
lado tomamos este 1 y lo comparamos con
todos los elementos que están antes 1 es
menor que 7 seguro que si uno es menor
que 7 así que cambiemos el 7 y lo
ponemos en el lugar donde está el 1
y podemos hacer dos cosas comparar con
el siguiente o simplemente poner el uno
donde estaba el siete y luego decimos ok
uno es menor que tres el uno es menor
que el tres entonces vamos a cambiar el
tres y lo ponemos en el lugar del uno y
ponemos el uno en el lugar del 3
entonces cómo está nuestra lista ahora
nuestra lista se ve como sigue 1 3 724 6
así que fíjense bien después de que
trabajamos con un índice en este caso es
el segundo todo lo que está antes queda
ordenado esta parte de aquí ya está
ordenada algunos de los elementos que
quedan a la derecha tal vez puedan ser
cambiados para acá claro que sí pero
estos ya están ordenados entonces cuando
lleguemos al final de la lista todo
habrá quedado ordenado
ahora vamos al siguiente índice o el
siguiente elemento de la lista y es este
2 que tenemos aquí este 2 de aquí y si
lo comparamos con el 7 el 12 es
definitivamente menor que el 7
entonces ponemos el 7 en el lugar del 2
y ponemos el 2 en el lugar del 7
ahora comparamos el 2 con el 3 2 es
menor que 3 claro que sí entonces
ponemos el 3 en el lugar del 2 y ponemos
el 2 en el lugar del 3
luego comparamos el 2 con el 1 todos es
menor que 1 no no es menor que 1 así que
no tenemos nada más que hacer ya no
podemos seguir a la izquierda en esta
pasada comparamos desde este 2 todo lo
que está antes después de esta pasada
nuestra lista se ve así
1 2 3 746 y noten esto todos los
elementos hasta el tercero todos hasta
el tercero incluyendo el tercero están
ordenados y estamos listos para revisar
el siguiente elemento de la lista hay
una cosa que quiero aclarar cuando
implementamos este ordenamiento hay dos
maneras de hacerlo como en este ejemplo
decimos 2 es menor que 7 si es menor que
7 y lo que hacemos es poner el 7 en el
lugar del 2 eso está muy bien pero no es
necesario poner el 2 en el lugar del 7
sino que seguimos comparando hasta que
encontremos un buen lugar para poner el
2 y cambiar hacia la derecha los
elementos que sean mayores y luego poner
el 2 esta es una manera sencilla de
hacer el ordenamiento
tal vez exploremos varias formas cuando
implementamos este algoritmo bueno
continuamos con este 4 es la misma idea
4 es menor que 7 si entonces ponemos el
7 en el lugar del 4 y ponemos el 4 en el
lugar de 7 4 es menor que 3 14 no es
menor que 3 así que nos detenemos
terminamos esta pasada todos los
elementos hasta el cuarto elemento están
ordenados y ahora voy a escribir la
lista como quedó después de esta pasada
la lista es 12
4 7 y 6 y luego vamos con este último
elemento en la lista este 6 no lo hemos
comparado la última vez que comparamos
un elemento fue el 4 ahora nos interesa
el 66 es menor que 7 por supuesto que sí
entonces ponemos el 7 en el lugar del 6
y el 6 en el lugar del 7
6 es menor que 4 16 no es menor que 4 y
aquí paramos porque sabemos que todo lo
anterior ya está ordenado y todos los
elementos son menores o iguales a 4
hemos terminado tenemos esta lista
ordenada y la lista ordenada quedó así 1
2 3 4 6 y 7 en el siguiente vídeo voy a
tratar de implementar este algoritmo que
he descrito aquí lo voy a implementar
como una función de payton